hello everybody and welcome to
our
last
refugee
program seminar for the semester
so today we have the pleasure of
having professor sandra rosso
who is going to be talking about the
brothers of invaders and how
crisis-driven migrants shape voting
behavior
professor brozo is a development and
labor economist and she works at the
marshall school of business at the
university of southern california
and her work focuses on firm decision
force migration diversity and
crime
um
so please
join me
welcoming professor rosso for the
second thank you very much for the
invitation i am i'm very very excited to
be here um this is a wonderful program
and i am very honored
uh for the invitation so um the paper
that i will present today is a paper uh
that in a nutshell to kind of give you
an overview of what i will be talking
about
a it evaluates the effects that
venezuelan migration has had
on
voting behaviors
and this is going to be joint work with
juan vargas from universidad rosario
so
before i begin i just wanted to kind of
bring this um
quote from the economist it was
published in 2018 to kind of motivate
what i will be talking about so it says
the fear of immigration is poisoning
western politics donald trump owes his
job to it and brexit would not be
happening without it strident nationals
will depart in italy hungary poland and
austra and austria and have gained
influence elsewhere so basically
a couple years ago there was already
this idea that
migration in many cases is used as a
weapon um in
the political arena and so this is one
of the ideas that we want to explore in
this paper
so just to motivate why we think this is
relevant um
i wanted to talk a little bit about
bring first my first displacement to um
to context so for displacement has been
increasing dramatically as of 2019 we
have almost 80 million people who have
been disforcibly displaced and just to
kind of give you know like a context or
put more context into this number this
is the size of almost two california so
we're talking about a very large number
of individuals here and most of the of
the migrants are hosted in developing
nations which is not surprising because
those are the neighbors of
of other of other conflict countries so
why do we think that
forced migrants deserve a different
analysis so forced migration has very
different characteristics than economic
migration so for one forced migrants
tend to arrive in very large numbers
they are also going through very
vulnerable journeys and and they they
arrive with no assets at all or very few
assets
typically forced migrants tend to be
disproportionately represented by women
and children and lastly they face large
uncertainty so when they are making
their decisions they don't have a
current
clear situation of whether they will be
allowed to stay or they will be moving
again or going back and for that the
decisions that they make
might be very different from the ones
made by an economic migrant
so
to kind of tell you a little bit of what
is known about the impacts that forced
migration and migration in general has
had on voting behaviors
um there has been very let's say
robert's recent work on trying to
measure what are the impacts that higher
first migration has had on the support
for right wing ideologies and political
participation
and in general most of these papers are
focused on developed countries and they
show that when the forced migration
influence increase
there is a surgery right-wing support
increases and there is kind of mixed
evidence on to what happens with voters
turnout some papers find this positive
and some papers find that that is
negative
so what are we going to do in this paper
what we're going to do is first try to
see if this is true also for a
developing country so what happens in a
developing country when you have a large
surge of first migration what happened
with voting behaviors
and then we're going to explore three
different mechanisms so one of them is
what we call the socioeconomic mechanism
which is basically trying to see whether
uh the economic impacts that force
migration might be having might be
driving this boating effects or these
political effects that we observe
and there is a couple more which are
cultural and electoral manipulation that
i will explain in a second exactly how
they are defined
so um
although there is a lot of evidence on
trying to measure how forced migration
impacts voting behaviors especially for
the northern countries of the world the
u.s europe
um
there is quite a debate on what is
driving this mechanism so as i as i
mentioned earlier there's probably three
main mechanisms that we're going to
explore in this paper one of it is what
we call the socioeconomic hypothesis or
the economic hypothesis which says
basically
that migrants react in in their voting
behaviors to migration because migration
creates
economic effects which could be positive
or negative in general we're pointing to
negative effects that's what most of the
papers actually find for example
migration might be increasing crime or
migration might reduce job opportunities
for locals and this is why they
basically react
uh with more antipathy
towards migration
another different hypothesis is that
migration basically creates this
in-group and out-group tensions in a way
such that the the nationals of a country
feel threatening their cultural views
relative to the migration or the
migrants that are coming in and so
that's another hypothesis this one
however we're only going to touch on um
tangentially because it's really hard to
prove that this is actually driving our
effects
and the last one which i think is our
main contribution and which we think is
pretty new
is that in in many contexts um
political parties use the migration for
example force migration
inflows to associate that migration with
their competing with their competing
party's electoral platform
uh in a way such that they demonize the
other uh parties so let me just kind of
explain better for example in colombia
what we see is that
the right uh wing parties basically
associated the venezuelan migration with
the venezuelan regime and say if you
vote for the left you will going to
become venezuela
um and that's what we call uh electoral
manipulation so we're gonna explore
whether that is actually affecting um
the effects that we absorb
so how is this presentation going to be
structured i'm going to extract it in
five parts so first i will briefly talk
about the venezuelan context for those
of you who are not familiar with it and
then i'll talk a little bit about the
data and pretty cool strategy the
results the general results
of the impacts of force migration on
voting behaviors and then i will talk a
little bit about the mechanism
so
here is uh let's say a short summary of
the share of venezuelan inflows as a as
a percentage of the colombian population
so just kind of give you an overview how
things have been going on uh in colombia
so
the venezuelan crisis
arguably begun with the election of fuku
chavez in 1988
but it is only until 2016 or if you will
2010 when you see an explosion
of inflows of venezuelans to colombia so
what happened why is this happening
so
in 1998 or before this let me just kind
of tell you a bit of what venezuela was
before this crisis began venezuela was a
very prosperous country so i i lived in
colombia i am colombian and i lived in
colombia for
more than 20 years and i remember very
clearly that a lot of my family and
friends will go to venezuela to work in
the oil companies technology was brought
from venezuela so in in our bu a lot of
colombians went migrate to leave
venezuela because it had better um
social safety nets better education it
was a very prosperous country
however in 1998 uber chavez was elected
president and he was a socialist
populist leader which introduced a lot
of constitutional amendments
expropriations of
private property and nationalizations
and he mainly used the oil rents to fund
all his populism
in 2013
nicolas maduro was appointed at his
successor and he strengthened all of
these policies and the crisis is
actually worse than there because he was
not as fortunate as chavez and oil oil
rents actually dropped the price of oil
dropped and the us also introduced very
drastic economic sanctions
so kind of to give you a little bit of
an overview of how drastic this crisis
is between 2000 uh 1998 and 2018
there was a contraction of 50 of the
venezuelan gdp
unemployment is approximately 40 percent
of of of the total labor force of that
country uh poverty rate is rampant
almost 90 percent there are shortages of
food and basic services
insecurity is very high and there is a
very large repression to the opposition
uh to the maduro's government
so not surprisingly there has been a
very large surge of migration outside of
venezuela to all of latin america so the
map that i am showing you on the right
is showing you the intensity of
migration flow so the darker the color
the more influence that country has
received
so colombia is the primary recipient of
venezuelan migration flows which by 2019
according to the u.n refugee agency were
um
were reaching 4.5 million individuals
and and of those 4.5 million 1.8 are
registered to be uh living in colombia
to stay
so one important kind of disclaimer
about this data is that typically this
data is going to be um
on the representation of the real real
amount of migrants that you would see
because of course um there is not um
a very
strong control of the of the borders of
the international borders and a lot of
migrants are afraid to be registered
because they don't want to be deported
or actually identified by authorities
so what are we going to do so basically
we're going to use data on on from the
electoral agency in colombia in two main
outcome one is what we call political
participation or borders turnout
and the other one is the political
ideology of each of the candidates that
are um
aspiring to the major or presidents in
the countries we're going to use data
between 1995 municipal annual data
between 1995 and 2018
and we're going to use data for six
first-round um presidential elections
and five second-round presidential
elections and six major elections so um
what is um let's say
a very hard work that we had to do was
first in identifying the political party
of each of the candidates that posted
for any of these elections that wanted
to be elected and then classifying each
of these candidates on left center or
right
according to
their own declarations or by actually
checking their government plan or their
campaign plan and classifying them
according to these views
so we're going to kind of see the
impacts that force migration had on
voters turnout and then on the share of
both to each of these orientations right
center and left
force migration data is going to come
from the colombian statistical agency
and then our construction
of let's say of primary source of
identification is going to come from the
population censuses of 1993 and 2005.
and this is a large set of controls that
we're going to use i am going to skip
this slide for now for time efficiency
so um
when we want to estimate the impacts
that force migration venezuela migration
has had on voting behaviors
we face this challenge that of course
migration is not random so both migrants
vote with their feet and they turn to
move to municipalities that for example
are more prosperous where they're they
feel safer that presumably are more open
to migrants and that is correlated with
body behaviors so what we're going to do
is basically exploit longitudinal
variation and we're going to explore two
sources of variation
one is we're going to use
cross-sectional variation coming from
the share of
venezuelans who arrived before the
beginning of the crisis to colombia
and this is the municipal level with the
early population censuses and the
temporal variation is basically going to
come from the overall
number of individuals are arriving from
venezuela to colombia
so the interaction of these two effects
is basically going to be what we call
the predicted venezuelan influence it is
going to try to tell us how many
migrants we expect to see in each of the
municipalities in colombia unfortunately
this is not going to be an iv strategy
or fortunately us
as how you see instrumental variables
but this is going to be more of a
reduced form estimation because there's
no data actual data at the municipal
level on how many venezuelans live in
each municipality
um and what is the assumption that we're
going to actually be using here is
basically that migrants tend to move
this proportionally to those areas where
they have pre-existing networks friends
family
and of course this is a very traditional
um
instrument used or proxy for migration
flows used in the migration literature
so here is
uh the specification form um more
particularly so why mdt are going to be
the political outcomes that we're
examining at the municipal level
um
m stands for municipality d for
department and t is going to be the
election year
and then we're going to try to see the
impacts that our measure of predicted
venezuelan influence has had on the
political outcomes
and this is coming from the instrument
that i just explained or the or the
variable that we we created
and we're going to control for it for
for a lot of covariates to kind of um
clean these confounders that may be
affecting the estimates of the theta
here that we want to identify one of
them is we're going to include
as much as we can baseline
at the municipality level interacted
with ear dummies the idea here is
basically to see or clean all of these
stories that may be confounding the
impacts of venezuelan migration and are
correlated presumably with our outcomes
we're going to include interactions of
department trends and near trends or
election year trends and we're going to
include fixed effects by election year
and municipal municipality
so here is how we constructed
specifically the measure of predicting
venezuelan inflow so it's going to be
corresponding to the interaction of the
cumulative venezuelan inflow to colombia
the overall national inflows this is
like let's say the temporal variation
interacted with the municipal variation
of early
venezuelan settlements in colombia this
is in 1993 which is the last population
census before chavez was elected in 1998
and we're gonna just kind of scale this
over the population of serving each
municipality
so to show you a little bit of um
the validity of this of this variable in
truly capturing
the venezuelan settlements at the
municipality level we did two exercises
one of them is basically using um the
predicted venezuelan inflows this proxy
that we're going to to use as venezuela
for venezuelan location and the data
that we have from the censuses to show
that indeed venezuelans are moving to
those areas
so on your left you have a map of
colombia divided by municipality in
which we're illustrating the predicted
venezuelan influence in 1993
and on your right we cross that figure
with circles that are larger
for the inflows that arrived between
1993 and 2005 so in 2005 of venezuelans
no in 2005 we observe another population
census and when we have population
census we have the unique opportunity to
truly verify where venezuelans are
located so you can see that there is a
large overlap between both variables and
that actually the correlation is strong
and significant
we did the same exercise but with the
last population censuses so uh we have
three censuses 1993 2005 and 2018 during
our period of
analysis um and the census of 2018
unfortunately does not allow us or we
haven't gotten access to the specific
nationality identifiers but we know
who's a foreigner the good news is that
of the whole share foreigners in
colombia
approximately 90
are venezuelans so we basically also
show a similar graph here in which we
show our early settlements of venezuela
in 1993 and the location of foreigners
in 2018 and again the correlation
between both variables is very very
large
so when you use uh bartik shift shared
instruments like the one that we we
constructed there there has been kind of
a very big surge of
um
critiques towards this type of variable
so here i'm going to kind of talk about
two main threats that might be affecting
the validity of this variable
um but we actually talk about more of
them in our paper
so the first one is one brought by
goldsman and penguin
being come in which he basically says
for this for this let's say variables to
be incredible what we need to show is
that
the the share part is actually valid
that it satisfies exogeneity um
the exogeneity assumption and so what
we're going to do to kind of address
this is basically include a large set of
covariates observe at baseline and we're
going to include here in our estimation
controls for economic growth measure as
nightlight density for
homicides for
previous
conflict for sheriff of agricultural gdp
in the whole economy so there is a very
large set of keywords that we're going
to include
um
in order to kind of account for
for this for this bias and we interact
those with election dummies or year
dummies to kind of non-parametrically
control for variables that may be
trending in time and driving biases in
our estimates
and another big let's say critique to
these instruments is that when migration
flows are consistent and you're trying
to use these instruments to identify the
effects of migration you are confounding
short and long-term
effects of migration when you when you
run these estimates and this is not
going to be such a relevant concern
because the migration the migration from
venezuela in colombia is a recent shock
it actually became endemic after 2016
and migration from venezuela to colombia
or in general from any country to
colombia was negligible before that time
so actually colombia is a very close
country internationally
so how do we execute our analysis to
kind of guide you to what i will be
talking about we first evaluate the
effects of force migration on boarding
behaviors that's the first thing i'm
going to do and then we're going to kind
of evaluate each of the three hypotheses
that i mentioned might be driving this
effects so first we're going to see if
is there evidence to kind of support the
idea that there are economic effects
driving this these effects that we
observe in voting behavior so we're
going to study the effects of migration
on labor outcomes and on
fiscal burden
because we think those are the two main
channels or the two main things that are
um
let's say um
beliefs that may be driving changes in
behaving voting behaviors in the
individuals that live in colombia
then we're going to kind of discuss why
we think the cultural hypothesis is not
really a very strong candidate to
explain what is going on in voting
behaviors and here we're not going to
have any empirical strategy because
there's not enough data at the municipal
level to actually carry out this uh
evaluate this this hypothesis
and then i'm going to kind of show you
what or talk a little bit about this
electoral manipulation hypothesis
why we think it's happening what is the
anecdotal anecdotal evidence existing
supporting that and we're going to also
show you some
empirical evidence that might support
why we think this is also an important
candidate for the effects that we
observe
okay
sandra
one question so when you have the
when you say that you're looking at the
election that they have is are these
elections are the
municipal level for major or for the
president or which elections are you oh
thank you
so this is a good question so we're
going to have
um three levels of elections so this is
all the municipal level so it's going to
correspond to the results of the
election at the municipality level uh
but we're gonna analyze the outcomes of
the presidential election first and
second round and the major elections
uh to kind of see whether they they kind
of translate across different types of
elections
um those are the three levels that we're
going to study so let me kind of show
you the results here
so panel is going to show you the press
the presidential elections for the first
round
um
so basically
whether there was more for example total
vote corresponds to voters turnout out
here
so
is not municipality do we see that more
people showed up to vote
for the presidential elections on the
second round and for the major elections
um so the first column in each of these
tables is or they are if you want the
odd columns are going to show you
the effects without including all of the
controls for
municipal
socioeconomic confounders that may be
affecting our estimates and the even
calms control for all of those so here
are kind of the um overall interactions
that were included for example conflict
and violence includes a very large set
of covariates that account for homicide
rates conflict um
threats robberies and and each of these
group of outcomes is kind of accounting
for each of these groups of different
threats that we could have on our
identification strategy so the second or
the even columns are the ones that we
think are or we view as our preferred
estimates of the effects of venezuelan
migration
so what do we see so in general across
all the lectures we observe
that when predicted venezuelan inflows
increase in standard deviations
the border turnout increases
this is true for the first round for the
second round and for major elections so
overall we see people tend to go more
and vote more
and what does that
translate to in terms of support for
left center and right wing
orient political orientation what we see
which is very much in line with what we
observe in other countries is that
higher predicted venezuelan inflows are
actually reflected in lower support
towards left-wing political identities
and more support from the right way for
the right wing so basically our
composition of votes from the left to
the right
and this is very robust across both
presidential elections and for major
elections one thing to kind of point out
is that for the major elections we are
not able to statistically um capture a
precise effect here but this has to be
is related with the fact that the last
major elections that we included here
took place in 2015
before the real surge in venezuela
migration took place
uh so in in a new version of this paper
we're actually going to include the last
major election that just have recently
took place and and that might kind of
allow us to have more power to see if
this becomes significant
sondra i'm sorry to uh interrupt you
right now
you're familiar with the um electoral
system in uh in colombia so could you
tell me um
why the number of observations is so
different between the different
elections
um yes of course so um
let's see so
for some this is the main reason
basically is that
in general there seems to be a lot more
information for the presidential
elections we observe a lot more
um political participation if you will
um in general
we should observe kind of uh voting
counts for all the municipalities of the
country but for some for some for some
election years there is now no data
available
and that's what probably would show the
different number of of observations
how it works is basically the
presidential elections work in a way so
that when candidates go and and try to
be elected for being a president if one
of them gets the majority plus one votes
then they are elected as president if
none of them gets this majority
then they go to a runoff um and the
first two candidates the ones that
receive more votes actually kind of
compete in a second round and whoever
gets the majority of votes that's going
to be the winner across the the whole
country
and major elections are just elected
through a simple majority rule uh
whoever gets the more votes at the
municipal level is gonna win
okay so the difference between the first
round the second row would be not every
presidential election went to a runoff
uh exactly yes yes yes yes that's that's
exactly that's exactly right
a lot of them so actually i think we
have six first round and five second
rounds in the in the period of analysis
got it but otherwise it's a balanced
panel so you have all the it should be
there but as i said there is some
municipalities that
didn't report first but they are not a
lot but but there are some minisplies
that did not report voting outcomes
and the vote is every four years for the
president and for the mayors is the same
it is um it is mostly four but at the
beginning of the period there were some
some changes in the in the timing so
initially it was three and then for that
for the rest of the period it was more
or less four
uh and this is why we have kind of a
different number so specifically we have
um let's see
[Music]
just quickly we have
six first round five second round and
six major elections across this period
1995 and 2018.
and do they vote at the same time for
president than for mayors no no
they don't
so there are other elections going on in
colombia uh but we decided not to work
in those because the classification of
the parties becomes more
complicated
a lot of
for example congressional candidates did
not have a very clear
agenda that it will allow us or enable
us to kind of classify them
as either center left or right or they
have conflicted policies that was made
very hard for us to make a clear
classification of their political
orientation and so that's why we decided
just to stay with these three elections
all right um so in general what we found
um is that whenever the predicted
venezuelan influence is increasing on
the standard deviation we see across all
of the elections so we examine
larger political participation
lower participation or lower support
towards the left-wing political
ideologies and and larger towards
right-wing and just kind of give you an
overview of how large these effects are
the mean support for the left for the
first round presidential elections was
0.10 and the effect that we're observing
when we increase the our our
measure of predictive venezuelan inflows
in one standard deviation is a change we
observe a reduction of 0.9 percentage
points in other words this is a 10
deviation
from the mean support for left-wing
political ideology so these are large
impacts
and and it is important to kind of take
into account that
since the support for left is not that
large in colombia we're talking about
very very important changes
so
before i move on to talk a lot about the
mechanisms i wanted to kind of mention
two
robustness tests that we kind of run to
test whether this was actually robust
these effects that i just showed you so
one was that we yeah we have a question
before you do that which is if the right
wing in colombia has a strong
anti-immigration
oh great question i let me just kind of
talk about this um in a couple of slides
i am going to talk about this but no the
short answer is no
we'll talk about that in a second i will
have a slide of that
so
i don't want to lose a lot of time in
this robustness stats but basically what
we did is we we had a lot of concerns
about the fact that maybe the the the
departments or the municipalities that
were located in the border with
venezuela had a different behavior
basically they were more pro-migrant or
less pro-migrant because they see or
have more exposure to migrants and so
for that what we did is we run our
estimates excluding different
departments of the country one at a time
and we run everything again and we find
very robust effects of everything that
i've showed you
another thing that we did is we say okay
maybe this instrument or this variable
is not a good proxy of of venezuelan
migration so let's use a different one
what if we use just distance to the to
the main border crossing locations in in
in the columbia venezuelan border
um and for that we calculated the
distance of each municipality to each of
these border crossings
and we run everything again and the
results are very very similar in fact we
actually found that
um there is a large correlation between
the variable that we're using and the
distance to the border um so that the
results are also very very similar
okay so now we're going to move on to
try to see what could be driving this
effect so remember there are three
possible mechanisms that we wanted to
explore and one is
maybe this is just economic effects
right maybe this is just migrants are
having a negative impact only for
example labor outcomes and we want to
see whether that there is some evidence
of that truly happening so the first
thing is exactly that checking whether
venezuelan migration has affected
outcomes in the formal or in folmer
sector
and for that what we use are the labor
force surveys in colombia and we
basically tested the main
labor outcomes hours work wages and
unemployment in the formal and informal
sector
and here i am showing you the results
it's a very similar identification
strategy
and what we see overwhelmingly is that
whenever there or in the municipalities
where there is a larger uh
inflow of venezuelan migrants
individuals colombia nationals are
working more
and they are they have a larger
unemployment rates and we also see some
let's say
suggestive evidence that wages are
dropping but
it's not enough to identify a
statistically significant effect so
this is somehow saying okay yes there is
something on the economic environment
that might be driving voting voting
behaviors
and then we
um said okay what else could be a main
important economic effect that migrants
could have that may be driving voting
decisions and we thought another very
important one was a fiscal burden so in
the sense that maybe
individuals are paying more taxes or the
government is sending more money to
those regions that are actually
receiving more migrants and for that we
use municipal
data on tax income per capita and the
government transfers
from the central government to the
municipalities and we see evidence of
both so we do see that it seems that at
a per capita level individuals are
actually paying more taxes and also the
central government is sending more money
to these municipalities that are
receiving more more migrants and so
it overall these two results kind of
give us a very good understanding that
there is something going on in the
economic dimension that might be driving
voting effects so we cannot
discourage or discard this hypothesis
that this socio-economic hypothesis that
this is there is something here at least
in colombia so the second hypothesis was
the cultural hypothesis which is um very
much in line with the question that i
just received from maria teresa saying
is it true that right-wing ideologies
are anti-immigrant
and so um for this this part of the
analysis we're not going to be able to
offer an empirical uh uh a statistical
analysis but we will kind of
talk to you why we think or try to
convince you why we think this is not
the main driver so the first thing is
that no right-wing ideologies in
colombia are not typically
anti-immigrants so in fact
uh the current president of colombia
ivan duque
is a very pro-immigrant president so he
has been supporting a very large amnesty
that has regularized
venezuelan migrants he has also given
them a very generous access to social
safety nets and recently to health
health coverage unlimited health
coverage to any migrant in colombia
and i think this is an important thing
to take into account because when we are
kind of bringing conclusions from the
north to the south uh we cannot
translate this right and left wing
orientations
in the same way so each country has
their different views or different
political let's say um agendas
identifying left and right and in
colombia particularly right-wing
ideologies are not anti-immigrant
another important thing to kind of
mention here why we do not think this
cultural hypothesis could be driving our
effects is that colombia venezuela are
culturally very similar so colombians
and venezuelans speak spanish and we
were part of the same country up until
1831.
we or the
very large vast majority of colombians
venezuelans have the same religion eat
similar foods and so for for all of
these reasons it's really hard to
ambition
that um the the boating behavior the
changing body behaves actually driving
by a cultural let's say xenophobic
reaction but of course this is not
something that we can prove a
statistically
and so the last um mechanism that we
wanted to kind of bring forth is what we
call the electoral malignation
hypothesis and again this is this idea
that the right might be using the
migration presence or the large
migration flows to say if you vote for
the left we are going to become the
country who actually expelled all of
these migrants right or in other words
the right saying we're going to become
venezuela if you vote for the left and i
am showing you just hear some anecdotal
evidence of banners posted all across
the country in which there were
different messages suggesting this idea
saying for example i don't want to live
as a venezuelan if you don't want to
leave us a venezuelan vote for duke
which was a right-wing president
candidate
um
columbia yep sorry sorry this is my
[ __ ] if i can just interrupt i
i'm just confused by the word
manipulation because manipulation sounds
a lot stronger than oh true yeah similar
messaging right
sounds like almost like cheating like
that's not what you mean you just know
that they're changing their messaging to
take advantage of absolutely i'm so
sorry yes you're absolutely right yeah
we i haven't thought about that yes
manipulation is we don't we're not using
this word to say that this is
uh illegal or cheating no not at all
it's just like a message they are used
kind of
using uh the migration to kind of
increase the beliefs that people have
about the effects that a left-wing
government could have but you're right
we have to think of a better name
i haven't thought about that so that
manipulation could be misunderstood all
right
so these are things that so these are
just a few uh of the banners that we
found online but this is widely
publicized all across colombia in the
last presidential elections and then
another thing that i wanted to show you
was do is it true that maybe the
majority of the voters in colombia have
these fears because maybe it's just a
minority or maybe they see the banners
that they don't believe it
um but here i'm just showing you more
let's say
anecdotal or maybe some some evidence of
the fact that there is a large majority
of colombians who actually think this is
true
so embalmer is a statistical firm a firm
that collects surveys in colombia and
they do a survey that is representative
of the majority of colombian voters 96
of the voters it's not representative of
the municipal level and this is why we
can't use it to run a statistical
analysis but at least we can kind of try
to see using the data that is collected
there
to answer this question it's true that
many colombians think this is true so
the question that this
firm asked was
colombia might be in the same situation
as venezuela in the near future do you
think that's true yes or no
and you can see that the the green line
is going to show you the share of
respondents who actually thought this
was a possibility that colombia might
become in itself
yeah cassandra sorry let me let me make
um
along the same lines a bit more of a
substantive point here right yes yes so
it it could be that people have these
beliefs it could even be that the
beliefs are correct who knows right
uh that there's a certain type of person
coming and their politics come with them
right now if the if if regardless of
whether the beliefs are correct if the
voters have the beliefs then you would
see that it might be actually sensible
in a political equilibrium for one of
the parties or maybe even both of the
parties right
to speak to those voters and adjust
their messaging and targeting strategy
in order to like tell the voters yes
this i mean tell the voters
right so for example fox news does a
great job of
cornering the market because you know
people not because fox news is making
people believe something but because
people already believe that and they're
happy to hear
what they're happy to hear from someone
what they already believe innately right
um same thing with cnn on the left um
and and so it's i think it's gonna be i
mean when you talk about it as a
mechanism right i think it's gonna be
really hard here to
ever
this disentangle you know the chicken
and the egg problem right is it that
voters believe this and politicians are
responding or is it that politicians are
taking advantage of this and making the
voters believe it i mean it's just a
really difficult problem to solve no
yeah i totally agree with you um they
are probably go hand in hand
um what is very interesting however is
that this has never happened before like
it seems like they appear at the same
time
um
this messaging and and the fears of of
colombians become and it's like well
yeah you're right absolutely right i
totally agree with you and i think
that's something that we need to
to
tread very carefully in in our analysis
about um
thank you moshik
so will you be able to tell us anything
i'm sorry to interrupt sandra um will
you be able to tell us anything about
the left is the left uh doing any
messaging along these lines are they
responsible mostly silent
well from from what we've learned um
mostly silent about this somebody's if
you say no that's not true that's not
true that's the truth but that's about
it
there's not really any messaging
concerning migration either pro
migration or anti-immigration from the
left in colombia okay they basically
don't talk about it
yeah
um yeah and so one thing that we so
because we don't have perception um
let's say uh
or or political attitude stayed at the
municipal level one thing we did was
well what if we could find some measure
that could kind of allow us to
have a proxy for how sensible um or how
much each municipality has been impacted
by past by the path by the left in the
past so
um you might not know this by colombia
was a country that had before the
minnesota migration had a very strong uh
internal conflict and that say that the
the beginning of this country of this
conflict uh was created by a lefty a
leftist group that was trying to spark
socialist sentiments in the country
and so often times when you talk to
people like what you've seen in colombia
is that the armed conflict presence is
kind of
viewed as the presence of the left in
many of these regions in colombia but of
course in later on in the process that's
something that i need to be very upfront
about other groups appeared which were
related with the right but originally
this conflict was sparked by uh by a
leftist group
so what we do in this exercise is we try
to evaluate whether there are
heterogeneous effects
on voting behaviors for those
municipalities where the armed groups
had a very strong past presence
um
so what we do is we create a dummy that
is equal to one if there was a very
strong presence of arm groups in the in
that municipality and what we see is
basically that those municipalities are
going to have disproportionate impacts
of venezuelan inflows in the dire in the
expected direction basically reducing
support towards the left and increasing
it towards the right
and another exercise which is very
related to this one we tried to clean
for
the type of group so there are many
different armed groups in colombia and
the one who is mostly
associated with the left is farc
and so what we did here is basically we
created a dummy to see whether those
municipalities that had a very intense
farc presence or where there was
more farc attacks if we see that those
have disproportionate impacts of voting
behaviors when venezuelans arrived
and again we see very very strong effect
for those municipalities again moving in
the same direction harder voter turnout
and a recomposition of both from the
left to the right
so although we cannot prove that this is
what is going on here what we can say is
there seems to be a very high
correlation with the bread with the in
that these behaviors are driven by
municipalities that have experienced
firsthand what could happen when the
left goes wrong
um and so it could be that in these same
municipalities the fears are are very
strong about the effects that the left
could have
in in colombia
so
to kind of wrap up my presentation um
what we observe here is that the large
migration inflows from venezuela have
had a very strong effect on voting
behaviors specifically we observe more
borders turned out and a recomposition
of both from left to right
we argue in in our paper and in in this
presentation that there's no support for
the cultural hypothesis saying
we don't see a very strong case for the
fact that there is a
resentment towards venezuelan from
colombians
but we do see some evidence or some
correlations that these effects might be
very related with the effects that the
migration has had on labor outcomes or
the fears
that
venezuelan
[Music]
that colombia might become a venezuela
if if they support the left but again i
think uh mushfiq points is is very valid
as to we can't really disentangle which
is the chicken on the egg there might be
things that happen at the same time and
are very very strongly correlated
thank you very much
i think
there was like
i think more than a question
what we have is that they said that one
of the participants is saying that there
is a paper by campante and
other authors showing that politicians
use the anti-immigration discourse in
the ebola outbreak context
and they call it strategic behavior
[Music]
of that i don't know if you're
super interesting yeah i can see how the
fears of contagion uh could also be used
as as
as an anti-immigration argument yeah
series
yes
the reason
hi um so my question is the analysis
covers a pretty long period i'm
wondering if have you checked if results
are different when you restrict to
migration you know before the current
crisis and migration after 2015 when the
political
uh discourse may be quite different
surrounding immigration
thank you jeremy that's a great question
so we we we tried to do that but
unfortunately it's not possible because
the
the let's say the this curse from
from from the right wing um parties as
to the the what we call the electoral
manipulation
um coincide very very dramatically with
the increasing venezuelan influence in
colombia so when we restrict our sample
period before 2016
which is where this discourse did not
existed in colombia venezuela migration
was negligible so we're not able to
really identify any effects like so with
a lot of power in other words it's a lot
of variation in in in
in the effects that this might be
causing okay so the results are
basically similar if you were to just
focus on the time oh yeah in 2018 if we
kind of focus on the last in the last uh
period the results are very low but what
when you lose the results is when you
move towards the past when when
venezuelan migration was not as strong
thanks
thank you
peter
yes
um
i'd like to make
a comment
on the beginning and the end
of your talk
thank you we started with the world
and in a generic way
we ended up with a great focus on two
south american countries
with
um
cross-border effects
now can we go back to the world
yeah yeah how would you how would you go
back to the world now
we see this everywhere
what's happening
um it's what's common everywhere
and uh
is there something to be
brought up from a comparison
for
the future what's happening in the world
is it uh popularism is it uh
globalism is it
you know what are people looking for
and
can your analysis and your methodology
help
um
help
thinking
leaders
to to to
help their peoples think
now we're talking to the world now
remember after world war ii
the terrible effects in europe
uh of the global wars
it created
a certain uh
determination
on the global level so that refugee
status is available
to anybody in the world who's in danger
of death in his own country
this is very important
where do we go from here
yeah yeah thank you uh peter a great
question um
so i think the the original motivation
of our paper was to try to see whether
the findings that you had on on
developing countries were translated in
a in a in a poor country
or in a country that has suffered more
dramatic inflows and we would you see
which is similar across the world is
that you see
that is true also for this context that
whenever there is a large migration flow
um
voting behaviors shift in a way that
they support less the right sorry more
the right and less the left
and you will see also that you see the
same behaviors in the northern countries
but what is very different um is that
these behaviors are not or we argue
we're not predominantly driven by
anti-migration behaviors but more for
fears of becoming the epicenter of
crisis like the ones they are observing
um and you would think that this is only
common about for example
latin america but in fact no if you
actually check uh what happened in the
last presidential elections in the u.s
um
there was a couple of uh very good
articles in new york times recently kind
of saying or suggesting that a similar
strategic behavior was used by the trump
administration to get the support of
latin voters in florida
so this is not something that is only
happening in colombia and it's only
unrelated with the rest of the world
this type of strategic behaviors could
also be used in the northern countries
to move
uh latin voters which are very important
to countries like the us and that are
you know sometimes
can can shift the outcomes of an
election and so in that sense um
it would be worth exploring how
important it was in in the us i think
that's a that's actually a paper that i
would like to to write in the future to
try to see whether that was important
for determining the election outcomes in
florida
well you know
can i speak again yes
after the second world war in europe we
had this whole
idea of certain unification
but the most important thing
is cultural and legal because
governments
humble themselves
by
allowing themselves to be taken to court
by individuals
in strasbourg we have the european court
of human rights which had great great
effects
now
in the united nations
the commission on human rights is simply
a
an
observatory
there's no there's no
you know
i mean people in russia
i just said naively used to think
in the days of communism that
you could take
you could take
your governments to go to the united
nations you can't
but it may be that this whole business
of migration
is really bringing us to a situation
where
the universal declaration of human
rights
needs to be supplemented by a new
universal declaration of national rights
this is a suggestion made by
saint john paul ii 1995 at the general
assembly
now you've got to think about this
carefully
you don't want
dictators
telling the rest of the world don't
interfere
in what's happening in my country why
see
such dictators oppressed people
so you'd have to have the declaration of
national rights
universal declaration of national rights
which in a way
reflects brexit
and uh trump in a way and the whole
popularism everywhere
but then it
needs to carry within itself
the subjection
to
human rights at the united nations
leveled by citizens of your own country
that's true
super thankful for your comments i i i
definitely think that um but i
i agree with some of the things you're
saying but i think there are kind of
different things to what we're kind of
analyzing in this paper uh all we wanted
to do in this paper was to try to see
what are the impacts that migration
flows could have on voting behaviors in
in a developing country and and what
explore what could be driving those
impacts um
so i guess that the the the sort of more
broad picture that you're asking about
would be kind of subject to a different
a different paper or or probably a
different analysis
we have a question by
wagner oliveira
okay can you hear me yes
so uh professor sandra it was really
great presentation a very interesting
paper
i was wondering about the mechanisms
specifically the socioeconomic ones that
you showed
so i have two questions concerning that
the first one is concerned with the
skill level of migrants if you have any
information on that because i mean there
is some evidence for the united states
for example that only low-skilled
immigration led to
voting for the right and not
high-skilled migration for example so i
was wondering if you have some
information on the
on skills of migrants compared to
natives yeah and the second one concerns
the the fiscal
uh uh burden that you showed like i i
think i saw that you showed both an
effect on tax revenue and transfers yeah
do can you see if there is like some
compensation between the two of them i
mean what is the effect on the on the
budget of like is the government
spending more relative to what it's uh
getting more taxes or
can you see that kind of uh information
oh thank you wonder both both great
great questions so on the skill oh sorry
yeah okay so on the skill question um
there is two things that i would say one
is that uh as i said earlier i don't
know if you if you recall venezuela was
a more a very prosperous country
actually more so than colombia so it
turns out that venezuelans in general
are more educated than colombian
nationals um to the order of one to two
years of schooling um however
as you see in many other conflict
situations or or forced displacement
situations this is not conflict but
humanitarian crisis
um
the the original or the first migrants
that that we have in colombia at the
beginning of the humanitarian crisis are
very educated and very wealthy and as
the crisis has progressed we see more
and more vulnerable so it is someone
could very very much argue correctly
that the very last migrants could be
less educated than colombian nationals
but if you kind of take into
consideration the whole picture of
migrants then on average they are more
educated so it depends on when you kind
of do the cut to measure that education
level
and on the second question um
we haven't done the net effect but this
is a great point and i think a great
suggestion to improve our paper thank
you
great thank you very much yeah we have a
question by martin
yeah thank you um
i was just thinking about the
generalizability of the results it seems
like it's very key to this specific
effect that it's a
left-wing ideology country that people
are fleeing from
and
um
this seems similar to the situation in
florida with cuban uh with cuban
refugees there but it seems very
different from the kind of refugee flows
that are coming into europe or you know
within europe uh and i was just
interesting if if there's um i was just
thinking about the framing of the paper
if it's possible to separate out
kind of types of refugee flows that are
coming because of a kind of natural
disaster or at least where it doesn't
have a clear
ideological kind of connection and
refugee crisis that are coming from a
country where there is a very clear
ideological uh kind of uh cause to the
to the crisis and and also i would say
that i would expect the effect to go in
the opposite direction if it had been a
right-wing dictatorship
uh you know in venezuela that caused
people to flee like according to the
mechanism that you were pointing to we
should see the opposite uh true yeah
yeah definitely great points i i
so of course this would be a different
more uh equally i guess
world um across world cross country
analysis but i definitely agree with you
that this is very specific of the fact
that the crisis was brought by a
left-wing government and and again the
same with florida with the cuban um
regime it would be very interesting i
think to doing another research to see
exactly that whether depending on the
ideology that begins the crisis whether
you see that the recipients of those
migration flows resent that party that
specific you know political orientation
and i guess that a great idea as you
pointed out would be a placebo testing
for natural disasters and see whether
that drives any behaviors um so yeah i
would be happy to write a paper with you
about that
it sounds like a wonderful idea
any more questions
i have one more quick question so i know
in some previous work you've also done
work with internal migration um and i'm
wondering if you know if that's still a
part of this research if you think
there's something you can learn by
comparing you know the effects of
internal migration with the effects of
international migration because colombia
has had so much internal migration yeah
jeremy that's a great question thank you
and yes you're right actually
the very early versions of this paper
compared both migration shocks so we
were trying to see whether the internal
migration had a different impact on the
venezuelan migration because they bore
both very large shocks
and very interestingly we find that the
internal migration had no effects on any
of the political orientation or any
voting outcomes in colombia at all
nothing towards the left or the right or
the center
um
what made it very difficult for us to
compare both situations is that they did
not coincide in time so they are not
contemporaneous so first we have the
internal migration and there was a
political you know environment and then
we have the the venezuelan migration and
both kind of take place
in different time frames and so
comparing them is complicated because of
that
um
but but yeah just to give you an of an
idea of what we found when we tried to
do that we did not find any impacts
that's interesting
and um
sandra so you were mentioning that the
at the beginning what you see
are inflows
of people that are more educated does
that have an effect on also on the
results that you have i mean are you
able to separate to pick that up from
somehow i see yeah so we we
unfortunately don't have the data to
know so
where for example the more educated
individuals are so
unfortunately colombia doesn't have a
very good tracking system to know where
the venezuelans are where is the like
they're
or if there is like a stratification of
location by education levels in the
country
what i think most commonly happens is
that they tend to move to enclaves so
wherever there is a you know a very
large settlement of venezuelans they all
move there like they're low educated and
they're highly educated so it's really
hard to tease out then
whether those locations have you know
different differential effects of both
types of migrants
uh but um but i know that there is a
largely teacher suggesting that um you
know the low um lowly the migrants that
have low education levels tend to be
direct substitutes for low-income
individuals and that creates sometimes
more you know resentment towards
migrants um and there is also kind of
mixed evidence on the fact of what are
the impacts that highly educated
migrants could have on political abuse
so when they bring money people tend to
like them uh and when they bring you
know new new firms new ideas new assets
people tend to like them uh
but sometimes still they rescind
cultural differences um and this is kind
of a of what what what i remember of the
literature
okay
the other question sorry is that you
mentioned about the
i mean the unemployment so
are the venezuelan also including this
informal in the measures that you have
of informal work yeah
thank you yeah do they have
the permit to work which is not normally
the case for other countries true so the
the special the almost uh case about the
developing countries is that um or the
southern countries of the world is that
many of them have very large informal
factors
and it is true that in in in the period
that was examined not all of the
venezuelans have job permits so in our
analysis we're only kind of focusing on
the impacts on natives so we only take
into account colombian nationals but in
general um venezuelans even if they
don't have work for meats they might be
working still in the informal sector the
informal sector is huge in colombia like
almost 40 of the economy and this is
true for all of developed countries and
so as such
even if the government is restricting
their entry to the economy the invader
will be very part of it a very very
active part of it um they might not be
able to enter the formal sector that's
the only part where the government might
have some control
but our analysis kind of cleans them
from this from the data there there is
some housing labor surveys directed to
venezuelans but we are able to identify
them in the survey so we can take them
out
sorry
apart from apart from the academic
aspect of your paper which seems very
very admirable
i'm wondering if
there's a drive
there's an objective
beyond science
in terms of
influence
or culture
because i think you you the science
isn't just for the sake of the science
it has to be for the sake of change and
progress
i'm wondering
where do you go from
this kind of analysis
right i guess our our main drivers of
course beyond
contribute to science is to kind of
by offering or trying to understand how
migrants impact behaviors you may be
able to presumably
um at least bring
an alert
to
um
strategic behaviors that might not will
be well intentioned or that might be
happening that people are not aware of
um
and i think that's that's as much as i
could say in that direction um
right now like i think informing and and
finding
what are the effects that migration can
have in a country and in views and
political attitudes
it facilitates trying to integrate
migrants trying to help them you know um
be part of a society and also kind of
prevents or brings an alarm on to what
type of behaviors are are happening that
might prevent those things from
happening but of course that's something
that we are not trying to do with this
paper this is just a purely academic
paper just informing of what are the
impacts but
yeah
that could be the the motivation for us
as a researcher to move this agenda
forward yeah
good
thank you very good
thank you thank you
thank you very much uh professor rosso
and uh yeah thank you
thank you
thank you very much for your talk a
pleasure to be here thank you for the
intention
you